well it sure is feeling like the
holidays outside and a local tradition
for the holidays is something that
families look forward to every year I'm
talking about glittering lights and it's
making its return to the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway we're joined this morning by
John Bentham the producer of glittering
lights to talk about all the fun that's
coming back it seems like it gets
earlier every year Maybe not maybe it's
just a sign of age I don't know John but
tell us what's new this year and you
said it's a little chilly out there so
it's kind of setting the stage for
glittering lights
Good morning Sherry and everyone yes
absolutely glittering lights at the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway is back for its
22nd year and though you brought the
perfect weather for us to be out here
this morning we're now in um what's
going to be our uh butterfly and uh our
butterfly tunnel uh where we've got lots
of butterflies and plants planted uh the
weather is perfect for this and um yeah
I mean you brought it it's I don't know
what you say in the 40s today and now
that we're in a tunnel we're a little
protected from the wind we've got lots
of great new things this year including
an increased uh Grinch tunnel
um fairy tale land is back in better so
I just can't wait to open up next week
on Thursday for everybody to see all the
great new displays oh it just it looks
absolutely beautiful for anybody who's
not been to glittering lights yet how
long does it take to drive through and
and just what's the experience like
yeah so we're a two and a half mile
completely drive-through course it can
take upwards of 40 minutes if you take
your time because really there's lights
to the left to the right above you and
all around you and you really take your
time and and can just enjoy it uh and
get into the holiday spirit you know
that's the one thing that um that we
need this time of year with all the
political uh noise in the market and
everything like that I think just to
kind of simplify bring back uh the
holiday spirit uh and really get you
into the mood yeah back to glittering
lights and uh yeah I mean it's a great
night I agree too you can just Pile in
the family and friends and take a car
load of folks and just put on some
holiday music so uh tell us where people
can buy tickets and when does it open
and when do tickets go on sale
sure we open exactly one week from today
we open uh Thursday November 10th at uh
4 45 p.m people can go to
glitteringlights.vegas for all the
information they can purchase tickets
online
um and they can also pre-purchase their
concessions which help benefit area Boy
Scout Troops and as a added bonus if you
bring a bag of gently used household
goods as a donation to Goodwill of
Southern Nevada you get five dollars off
at the gate you can also go to any
Goodwill site throughout the town and
get a five dollar off coupon when you
donate or make a purchase at a store and
a ticket start for the entire car uh for
as low as 24 oh that's fantastic John
and I love it that you always give back
to a local charity as well and that's
good that you're collecting household
goods and clothing for Goodwill so thank
you Joe and a portion and a portion of
each ticket goes directly to Speedway
Children's Charities so yeah you're
helping in every direction possible so
it's it's a great event that gives back
a lot to the community wonderful and boy
scouts are selling concessions so
they've got the kettle corn that I love
it sounds like a great evening it sure
does thank you John so nice to see you
again and happy holidays